tyler alexander just pinpoint
accuracy great control to a board with
only one away
and now it's jose abreu the cleanup man
jose lines it to left center field
that's down for a hit
as he gets to the tigers one more time
ta welcome back he scores
and jose slides into second base second
and third one go on and there's your
offense to start the night first and
third
two out and de loy who hit the ball
quite hard a couple of times yesterday
sends this one in the air to right field
demerit back at the track in the wall it
is gone
[Applause]
three run home run eloy he sucked a
couple last night this one leaves it's
four to nothing
some early offense as alloy goes
opposite field that is the sweet spot in
detroit
jose abreu delivered a run with a double
in the first this could help
how about two scope calmly does turn it
and that's exactly what tyler alexander
needed
first walk issued here by geo gonzalez
now the first two have reached and now
it's back to the top of the order
for nico goodram it's four nothing white
sox here in the third
third base monkatta stops the bag goes
across the way and a stretch from jose
for a double play that's what i was
talking about earlier
if he's off balance and doesn't have
time he usually makes a pretty good
throw
as we go to the fourth inning at america
park it'll be edwin encarnacion to lead
it off
edward drive deep left field
bring him home it is gone
and the parrot visits detroit no doubter
he got every bit of that and it's a five
run lead
just his second home run just his third
driven in but he's back in the lineup
and giving the socks another power bat
third time detroit has had a player at
least one
in scoring position and now they've got
jonathan scope there with two away
gonzalez pitch swung on and missed
there's strike three inning over so no
runs
but one hit and one man is left so here
is austin roman is single up the middle
as last time
romine sends it to deep left back it
goes and that ball's gone
into the white sox bullpen austin romine
with a two-run shot
his second of the season and the tigers
have broken through
right there shep that's what they need
to get the first guy on
and get a blast right there and now all
of a sudden you're saying right back in
the game
five to two hanging on there at second
base is jose abreu now with one away
here comes eloy jimenez right side line
drive a rocket right down the chalk and
pinging
right to demerit in right field abreu
hustles home and that balance kept
deloitte jimenez to a single but no
matter
the sox make it six to two on an
absolute demon shot down the right field
line
and now you've got first and third
nobody out looking for a little
insurance
eight-game hitting streak on the line
for montana as well there goes anderson
and moncada rolls one to lugo run will
score
and anderson's gonna keep on churning
all the way to third
one ball one strike third base side
fair a paint tracer all the way into the
corner finally crossing the line
eight to two socks tim has scored two
runs which is exactly what you're
looking for from a leadoff hitter
welcome back to the lineup jose drives
him in
zach birdie comes into this following up
matt foster who was wonderful through
two
matt four strikeouts nothing else and
zach bertie on for the second time
the first time his major league debut
was
very impressive and the 1-0 pitch hit in
the air pretty well into left center
field
tracking that one all the way though is
luis robert in the alley he'll make the
catch for out number one
that one hit it in the air to center
drifting over now toward left center is
luis robert looking up and making the
grab for out
number two a couple of fly outs to
center field two outs in the eighth
inning eight two white sox and here is
miguel cabrera
off the mound tim's got it off the hop
and the innings
one two three go the tigers and their
half of the eighth will head to the
ninth
white sox eight tigers two three outs to
get and for you broadway fans
bye bye birdie now hamilton
comes out to try to wrap it up with a
six run lead castro goes to left wing
out
on a bounce one run will score
candelario will be held to third harold
castro comes through
in a pinch-hitting situation to get the
tigers within five
one out new pitcher is steve seashek
eight games no wins losses
on the ground tim it's short turn from
mending is a little bit late
and the tigers get a run it's eight to
four but the sox will make that trade
certainly
one two is golf towards second mendic
will pull that out of the air the white
sox have ended their three-game losing
streak they get an 8-4
win in detroit